he sees human yours today we're gonna
read problematic Christmas lyrics
because if someone needs to speak out
let's go into a lyric show first song up
is Santa Claus is coming to town you
better watch out you better not cry
which is the beginning of also horror he
sees you when you're sleeping he knows
when you're awake is he god it's either
creepy stalker or I guess guys should we
play this backwards and see if it's like
Satan is coming if you turn the words
around Santa is Satan I saw Mommy
Kissing Santa Claus
I saw mommy tickle Santa Claus
underneath his beards of snowy white
that covers a lot of ground
tickle tickle fickle fickle pickle
pickle
as a child you're used to seeing your
mom and your dad and then suddenly this
dude comes out of nowhere snatches your
mommy go tinkle mommy what a laugh it
would have been if daddy had only seen
it you know to be funny oh it wouldn't
have been a laugh at all this kid seems
like he's trying to break up a happy
home wait out of how this story should
have happened police yes I'd like to
report an adulterer grandma got ran over
by a reindeer you had not heard that no
at the scene of the attack there were
hoof prints on her forehead
incriminating claws marks on her back
closets belt CL aus
Santa's into some BDSM grandma laid down
with Santa too and it seems like mommy
wasn't the only person kids yeah yeah
yes I'm piecing it together one and
grandma goes outside for a whiskey and a
smoke see Santa slithering down the
chimney and invites him to do the same
to her we should consider that maybe
this was a consensual act resumed Santa
Claus reindeer and grandma and it just
got a little out of hand let's just have
a moment of silence with her mom yeah
okay
santa baby this is my favorite think of
all the fellas that I haven't kissed
next year I could be just as good if
you'll check off my Christmas list this
is a letter to her sugar time I'll do
this if you do this she once said one
morning a duplex and some checks so you
you just want straight money is also
what she wants I need to take some notes
from earth away Santa theythey give me
money for my rent this month maybe Santa
is just like the Hugh Hefner of like the
world and he's just like kissing mom
taking down and Eartha Kitt is the side
chick and they're just like a crazy yeah
I don't know if it's like it sounds more
like a leader of the mob or something to
me baby it's cold outside I simply must
go the answer is no that's it that end
of song well maybe just a half a drink
okay put some records on while I pour
the neighbors might think I'll say
what's in this drink after half a drink
you've been roofied honey after six
drinks I'm still standing so don't tell
her it's cold outside give her a
freaking jacket in the scarf and keep it
moving yeah drive her home there you go
call her over if it's Cobra if a girl
says I want to go home let her go home
if a man says I want to go home let him
go home and it's she's like you've been
really been grand and after he said all
this horrible stuff to her it's like
women we just feel like you don't want
to hurt people's feelings even when
they're horribly creepy and that's
what's going on with this girl she's got
some dark so quick communicator game
damn man you already knew was a head saw
I don't even know it I was like still
singing it like just gonna go back to
Spanish songs just talk about candy and
boots 27 2017 2017 needs to make some
new [ __ ] Christmas so seriously I'm
still gonna listen to him
me too my person
hey-ho baby it's cold outside we're out
[Music]